he made a lot of people happy it's sad
to see him go Michael Pena opening up to
et about the death of Marvel comic
legend Stan Lee
well the 60s were fun but now I'm paying
for it it is a sad week in the Marvel
family with the death of Stan Lee yeah I
know you've met him before is there any
experience that or any story you can
share about meeting him well I know that
what I you know there was one time that
I met him after the first half man
premiere and he's like I want to take a
picture with you what you saw the move
and he's like you did great you did a
great job boy or whatever he said I just
felt so cool it was really cool Lee had
cameos in Pena's 2015 flick ant-man and
28 teens ant-man and the wasp an
agnostic tells me going I meant the
crazy fine writer chick at the spot last
night like fine fine like crazy stupid
fine and he goes up to the bartender
goes look at the girl I win you'll say
he's pleased to be fine right
the bartender's all like yeah
crazy-stupid fine the guy wrote a bunch
of characters and you know created this
entire universe and you know he made a
lot of people happy and he's the one who
really said like if you're if you're
different that makes you special and he
was one of those guys that really
believed that and it's sad to see him go
et sat down with the actor to talk about
his role on Netflix's hit drama
narcos Mexico which tells the story of
Mexican drug lord Miguel Felix Guyardo
and undercover DEA agent Kiki Camarena I
put in my life into this job what I want
to see is change
this is such heavy material but you're
kind of known for being really
light-hearted and really funny did you
bring any lightness to set or was it
kind of like staying in the zone this
one to be honest with you it's it's
tough I didn't I wasn't able to put that
much humor into it because there was no
time frame you know when you're on a
chase and you're on a shootout or
whatever there's no time to be like you
know what does it matter
you know cuz cuz you can get shot it's a
funny story I'll tell you don't you know
so there wasn't too much time for